es schaut einfach cool aus es ist ja
artistisch und und das gefällt ihnen
glaube ich und dann das Gefühl durch die
Luft zu fliegen ist einzelartig
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen beim Sportplatz dem
Sport Podcast des österreichischen
Bundesheers heute zu Gast gefeiter
dadurch Schlotti herzlich willkommen
danke
bei Europameisterschaften sowie die
meisten anderen weltkämpfe ist ein Meter
noch dazu
ob man mit der nur einzelne ist kein
Grund was bringst du denn am liebsten am
liebsten ich bin noch im herausfinden
ehrlich gesagt ich bin noch ziemlich
früh mit meiner Carrera ähm ich habe
Zeit mich noch wirklich zu
spezialisieren aber ähm das immer
lustigen Mann dann synchron mittlerweile
du meinst Anton Partner sehr jung
Partner muss man dazu sagen gibt es auch
schon einige Erfolge gemeinsam gefeiert
oder ja ja war er ist auch bei der
Jugend WM Vierter geworden ich muss
langsam echt aufpassen auf dem Knall
oder gemeinsam gute springen und
gemeinsam die Erfolge feiern du hast
gesagt du bist noch im finden ist es
beim Wasserspringen nicht so dass man
sagt wie beim Schwimmen keine Ahnung der
schon gut Brust das wird ein
Brustschwimmer und dann schwimmt er nur
noch Brust könnte wirklich dazwischen
dann den den Höhen und und den Bewerben
noch wechseln und noch fühlen wo ihr
euch wohler fühlt genau ja also ich
glaube es ist weniger Körperbau abhängig
man kann ja immer wechseln eigentlich
es passiert sehr oft das einer mit 20
21 sagt okay ich bin nur noch
Turmspringen und nur noch brettspringer
aber ich glaube auch der Fall dass das
viele die ganze Karriere durch beide
gesprungen sind oder auch spät mit fast
30 gewechselt dann haben also ja möglich
ist es in Österreich hatten wir sehr
gute Turmspringer vor vielen vielen
Jahren natürlich auch Medaille gewinnen
aber in ähm letzter oder Vergangenheit
der konzentrieren
gesagt haben bei Großereignissen ist das
auch etwas wo du sagst
da möchte ich auch hin ja auf jeden Fall
also wie ich wie ich nach Österreich
gezogen bin habe ich immer zum zum
Gucken zum Fabi raufgeschaut das wäre
mein Ziel es ist immer noch mein Ziel
und ich ich merke dass dies auch sehen
und dass dies auch feiern wenn ich wenn
ich dabei bin du hast jetzt gesagt als
du nach Österreich gekommen bist das war
2016 davor ich bin ursprüngliche
Engländer also bin in England geboren
und aufgewachsen bin mit 15 dann nach
Österreich gezogen ja wie war das für
dich die Umstellung aus England nach
Österreich nicht so wie es mir
vorgestellt habe ehrlich gesagt aber ich
bin mit mit offenen Armen empfangen
geworden ich bin immer willkommen und
und ja ich finde es wirklich cooler hast
du schon in England Wasserspringen
gemacht ich habe mit mit 12 begonnen
also
2012 2013 begonnen ja und bin dann 33
Jahre später nach Österreich gezogen für
den Sport oder das genau wie wie bist du
dazu gekommen dass du sagst ich möchte
nach Österreich warte mein Vater war ja
auch Springer und hat man jetzigen
Trainer in Graz gekannt und und hat sich
gedacht okay dari hat bessere Chancen
wenn er jetzt nach Graz zieht und dort
weiter macht und das ist
bisher sehr gut gelaufen England weiß
man es ja eine
sehr sehr erfolgreich und sehr sehr gute
wassersprung Nationen sehr sehr starke
Leute immer gehabt in vielen Disziplinen
werden da die Rahmenbedingungen nicht
nicht besser gewesen als in Österreich
die jetzt bekanntlich nicht unbedingt
die größte wassersprung Nation ist na es
war schwer Aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen
und ich bin auch muss man sagen ich bin
fast 2 Stunden weg vom Bad gewesen da
ich bin jeden Tag rund vier Stunden
gebändelt es ist sehr anstrengend und
mit der Schule wäre es auch nicht so
leicht ausgegangen also in Graz vor
allem mit dem Sportpark ist es wirklich
wirklich unterstützt worden der Sport
und deshalb bin ich noch gerade gezogen
mit 12 Personen angefangen in welchem
Alter fängt man normalerweise an mit
Wasserspringen Teufel ist ziemlich spät
also normal würde ich sagen wenn man
früh gut dabei sein will ja 56 wäre wäre
es langsam Zeit da daran zu gehen
[Musik]
ich glaube mein Papa war ehrlich gesagt
ein bisschen nervös er wollte nicht dass
ich dass ich so früh anfangen es ist
halt beim Wasserspringen hohen
Verletzungsrisiko dabei aber er hat dann
wieder mit masterspringen selber
begonnen ich habe ihm zugeschaut und
wollte unbedingt mitmachen was hat er
denn so gefallen aber springen also
erstens wie es ausschaut also bevor ich
kaputt probiert habe es schaut einfach
cool aus es ist ja artistisch und und
das gefällt ihm glaube ich und dann das
Gefühl durch die Luft zu fliegen ist
einzelartig
und dann hast gesagt na dann probiere es
einfach mal selbst hast du gleich
gemerkt das würde mir gefallen ja ja war
am ersten Tag schon ja habe ich gewusst
ja das wäre was für mich und war damals
auch schon bewusst dass das bedeutet für
für Training und für Aufwand nicht so
nein aber ich habe einfach weitergemacht
also ich habe auch immer eine
Jugendmusik gespielt mit meinem Vater in
einer Band und da hat er mich äh ein
bisschen trainiert sozusagen ins
Training also ich habe ich habe das
Training in der Jugend schon trainiert
und habe einfach weiter gemacht was hat
denn Vater für
Erfolge im Wasser springen dann fahren
können er war 14 Jahre lang
Staatsmeister in dem Iran der war auch
bei die asische Meisterschaften dabei
nicht bei Olympia aber das wäre ja mein
Ziel das heißt hier auch den den Traum
in der Familie sozusagen
weitergeben und dass du ihn dann
erfüllst hast du als Kind mitbekommen
von deiner Folgen deines Vaters
eigentlich nicht nein also es war
irgendwie in meinem Hinterkopf ja der
das einmal irgendwie gesprungen aber ich
habe nicht gewusst was das wirklich
bedeutet im Nachhinein ja wäre es
vielleicht besser ein bisschen früher
dran zu gehen aber ich kann nicht
gewusst aber ja ich freue mich dass ich
jetzt da bin auf jeden Fall 2021 zum
ersten Mal bei der Weltmeisterschaft in
der allgemeinen Klasse am Start wie
siehst du jetzt deine Bilanz wenn du
siehst der Sprung aus dem Nachwuchs in
den allgemeinen Sport in den Erwachsenen
Sport ist ja in dem Sinne schon
vollzogen worden ja ja er hat zwar
wirklich komisch jetzt die Jugend WM
anzuschauen und ich kenne fast kein
Gesicht die also wirklich wirklich
lustig für mich aber ich glaube ich habe
es gut verstanden ich war in der Jugend
aber auch immer anspringer der er auf
auf die schweren Sprünge gegangen ist
also in der Jugend springt man ja zehn
Springer davon fünf leicht und fünf
schwer und in der allgemeinen Klasse nur
sechs schwere Springer deshalb war es
für mich glaube ich
leichter als für anderen vielleicht
umzusteigen in die allgemeine Klasse
warum liegen dir die schwerspringe das
ist eine gute Frage ich glaube
auch in England habe ich schon damit
begonnen okay die Einstellung war ich
habe so spät begonnen ich muss einfach
so schnell alles mögliche schaffen und
alles mögliche machen deswegen haben wir
zuerst die Sprünge geschafft und dann im
Nachhinein darauf konzentriert okay
jetzt einmal da was ändern da was ändern
schön machen und und perfektionieren
aber ich bin eher einer der zuerst macht
und dann verbessert als bei jedem
kleinen Schritt weiß ich nicht zwei drei
Wochen zu brauchen wie kann man sich
dieses perfektionieren dieses verbessern
vorstellen du hast einen Sprung äh du
hast Schwierigkeit gerade schwieriger
die Sprünge sind desto mehr Punkte gibt
es wenn du dann machst du dann den 100
mal und machst Videos und schaust du das
an oder wie kann sich das vorstellen
also im Aufbau von von einem Sprung
schaut so aus du machst vielleicht vom
vom ein Meter ein eineinhalb vorwärts
oder ein doppelten und dann gehe ich
aufs Dreier und machst dann zweieinhalb
vorwärts oder ein dreieinhalb vorwärts
vielleicht und es wird immer aufgebaut
von einem Tag auf dem anderen aber man
kann dann im Nachhinein okay ich mache
den Sprung zuerst und dann schaue ich
dass die Spannung besser ausschaut oder
dass ich mehr nach oben springen bei bei
jedem Sprung und es wird einfach bei
jedem Training ein bisschen besser das
System halt man weiß ja von euch dass
ihr wahnsinnig athletisch seid und auch
sein müsst weil er ja da enorme
Körperspannung hat und das ist ja auch
wichtig für die Sicherheit oder auf
jeden Fall ja ich habe mit mit 13 und
halb fast 14 Jahren man meinen Rücken
gebrochen beim Springen und seitdem eben
im Bauch und im Rücken eine eine enorme
Körperspannung aufbauen müssen weil es
ja sonst nicht geht was ist da passiert
wenn ich schwanger
ja ich bin halt ins Wasser komisch
gelandet und habe eine eine kleine
Fraktur im unteren Rücken bekommen und
war sechs Monate fast nicht am Sport
machen und es hat mir auch gezeigt wie
wichtig das Sport ist für mich
persönlich für meine mentale Gesundheit
eigentlich und ähm ja seitdem weiß ich
was ich brauche körperlich und mental
von Sport wie kann man sich das ungefähr
von der Fahrt von der Aufteilung
vorstellen wie viel Prozent ist ein Land
liegt die Training Körperspannung
rumstabilität wie viel ist wirklich
Wasser und dann Brett also von von den
zehn elf Einheiten manchmal in der Woche
sind
zwei oder drei im Kraftbereich
vielleicht einmal Ausdauer sonst sind
alle Trainings was Einheiten aber davon
von den Wassereinheiten ist mindestens
eine halbe Stunde einer
Dreiviertelstunde im Trockenbereich eben
um Rücken Bauchübungen viele sagt dies
auf einer Matte trockenbrett im besten
falschen Österreich nicht gut möglich
aber auf Trainingslager auf jeden Fall
viel in der Schnitzelgrube das jetzt
eben Deine Verletzung angesprochen das
zeigt halt auch dass die Sportart
gefährlich ist auch dass dein Vater dich
dann nicht unbedingt sofort hinein
geworfen hat ins Wasser
wie gefährlich kann man denn sagen dass
Wasser springen ist ja also
Leistungssport generell ist glaube ich
nicht unbedingt das gesünder aber wenn
man sich auskennt und wenn man wirklich
auf dem Körper achtet und aufpasst dann
kann es gar nicht so gefährlich werden
ich meine ich kann man immer die Freak
excellen sozusagen aber wenn man brav
trainiert und und wirklich darauf achtet
dann dann kann eigentlich nichts
passieren ich nehme andere wenn man blöd
am Wasser aufprallt wie du vorher gesagt
hast oder auch falsch Weg springt oder
die Rotation zu früh aufmacht dass es
dann halt so zu Unfällen kommen kann wie
du gesagt hast man kann eben sich
vorbereiten geht man da durch und schaut
sich an welches Szenario kann denn
passieren und wie kann ich dagegen
wirken genau ja also man schaut auch im
vorhin aus okay der letzte Sprung war
vielleicht ein bisschen knapp beim
nächsten ein bisschen weiter weg
springen und arbeitet so dran also im im
immer auf sicher gehen und im vorhinein
schon
herausschauen was könnte da passieren
wenn so weitergeht könnte das passieren
okay wir waren es ändern brauchst du
doch den Blick von draußen ist der
Trainer sagt hey ich glaube auf jeden
Fall langsam wirst du vielleicht
schlampig mit der Durchführung und nicht
dass du dann so nah dran bist
mit
Videoanalyse also wir haben in Graz
nicht aber in Wien haben wir einfach
einfach einen eine Kamera die die ganze
Zeit läuft und an Bildschirm mit
Verzögerung mit 10 20 Sekunden wie noch
immer und da springst du rein kommst
raus aus dem Wasser schaust den Sprung
an da drinnen sagt was dazu und dann
verbesserst du das was zum verbessern
ist beim nächsten Sprung also ich sehr
spannend finde bei euch ist die
Wahrnehmung von von außen und von innen
also wie hat sich dein Sprung angefühlt
für dich und wie hat er von außen
ausgeschaut liegt das oft nacheinander
oder kann das auch
das Ziel das ist nacheinander liegt und
das trainieren wir auch also das
Körpergefühl trainieren wir ja auch aber
manchmal ist es äh sehr überraschend
wenn es rauskommt sagt na das war jetzt
nicht so gut und was das habe ich doch
gesehen gespürt oder was noch immer aber
wenn er Video beweist da ist da ist halt
wirklich wichtig manchmal zu sehen okay
doch nicht oder das ist doch passiert
das ist doch passiert ich kann das
verbessern
jetzt gehört das Wasser springen auch zu
den Sportarten die subjektiv bewertet
werden das heißt es gibt Wertungsrichter
die sich jeden Sprung anschauen ob die
Schwierigkeitsgrade erfüllt wurden
gegebenen Punkte ist das fair oder wie
würdest du das beurteilen ich würde
sagen es ist ja ziemlich fertig also
viel besser als vielleicht manche
anderen Sportarten
bei uns werden die die Wertungsrichter
auch selber gewertet und wenn du da
Zufall zu weit rausfällst zu hoch oder
zu niedrig wird es zu oft wirst du auch
nicht zu den ganzen WMS oder Ems
eingeladen also ich glaube ungefähr 90%
muss man drinnen liegen als church und
da überhaupt dabei sein zu dürfen wenn
man sich einen Namen gemacht hat ist es
manchmal ein bisschen unfair aber das
ist alles subjektiv und ich glaube es
kommt sehr selten vor dass alle außer
die Wertungsrichter einverstanden sind
das Navigation unfair war glaubst du das
da auch technische Möglichkeiten dass
man Sprünge filmt und und Algorithmen
analysieren wann der Sprung geöffnet
wurde ob die Drehung komplett gemacht
wurde glaubst du dass das auch in den
Zukunft hätte gute Frage also weil es
ist noch so dass es eigentlich lustig
dass man Wettkampf ist die Zuschauer
haben ja ein Bildschirm und es wird dort
hingestellt wo die judgets die Punkte
Richter das nicht sehen können damit sie
eben im Nachhinein nicht schauen können
die sehen nur einmal den Sprung live und
werden uns dann wäre spannend zu sehen
ob das dann mit Video Beweis im im
Nacken Zukunft kommen wird aber ich
vermute dabei brauchen wir es noch nicht
was du schon mal Wertungsrichter bei die
anderen Wettkämpfen ja genau also bei
den bei den Staatsmeisterschaften war
der Masters oder auch beim steirischen
bin ich ab und zu immer dabei es ist
ganz lustig eigentlich wie wie gehst Du
da diese Rolle an worauf muss man achten
beim Sprung es gibt eigentlich fünf
Teile vom Sprung die man achten soll der
erste Star der Absprung die Richtung
sozusagen wie hoch wie niedrig wie weit
wie knapp die Drehung wie schnell die
Drehung ist die Spannung das Aufmachen
vom Sprung und das ist tauchen ist
eigentlich das wichtigste sollte nicht
sein aber es ist Letzte was die Punkte
richtig sehen und wenn ein Sprung
wirklich gut getaucht ist kommt immer
mindestens zwei drei Punkte dazu ja das
ist das was man auch wenn man Wasser
springen in der weiten Öffentlichkeit
hat bei Olympischen Spielen immer darauf
achtet wie sehr spritzt ist
dann weiß man der macht jetzt vielleicht
der eine Medaille jetzt gibt's natürlich
das Wasser springen in
Wilderer Formen auch tiefdiving zum
Beispiel ist das etwas für dich das wäre
schon was für mich ja also ich bin noch
nicht bereit aber beim high diving lief
diving muss man muss man sich wirklich
Langzeit nehmen ich habe auch mit mit
vielen geredet bei der EM jetzt letztens
und dem allgemeinen die beste advice die
man haben kann ist einfach sich Zeit
nehmen weil wenn da was schief
vielleicht kann es wirklich gefährlich
werden
also reizt mich schon aber ich mache mir
kein Druck kein Stress jetzt bist du
natürlich immer auf so einem Turm in der
Höhe ja drei Meter ist jetzt noch nicht
so hoch ich habe trotzdem sie ist sehr
viel Panik von 3 m oder vielleicht zu
springen 5,10 m geht dann wirklich schon
hoch muss man mit der Höhe klar kommen
ins Wasser springen oder kann man auch
super Wasser springen werden man kann
auch mit Hörner Angst
gut springen ja ich springe sagen wir
nicht Angst sondern Respekt man weiß
okay wenn wenn ich da was ganz falsch
mache wenn was ganz schief läuft dann
wird wirklich weh tun man übrigens auch
gefährlich werden aber das hilft ja den
Sprung besser zu machen dann Springer
mehr aufmerksam zu machen und deshalb
sagen wir ja keine Angst aber Respekt
das ist Respekt aber eigentlich eher vor
dem vor dem Schmerz oder Konsequenz aber
nicht unbedingt vor der Höhe selbst oder
also genau ja am Turm gestanden und das
runtergeschaut und die gedacht war heute
wirkt das alles irgendwie viel höher ich
mag nicht oder ja es passiert manchmal
hat man einfach schlechte Tage manchmal
auch wenn du an einen neuen Sprung
probieren willst es schon einer
Überwindung weil musste denken du kannst
nicht so gut vorbereiten kannst vom 5er
100 mal einen zweieinhalb rückwärts
machen
aber wenn du auf Szene drauf gehst und
zum ersten Mal dran rückwärts probieren
willst ist es trotzdem das erste Mal
dass du überhaupt diese Bewegung machen
wirst beim ersten Mal muss man manchmal
wirklich sagen okay egal ich mache es
einfach wenn schief läuft schief da muss
man sich vorbereitet sein okay wenn es
weh tut weh aber es ist halt ein Teil
vom Sport und ich kann es dann im
Nachhinein immer ausbessern das
dingliche Tipps und Tricks wie ihr die
Schmerzen dann wegbekommt wenn du mal
irgendwie falsche auf knallste wegkommen
ganz rot ist wegbekommen weiß ich nicht
ja Eis ist immer gut aber ich muss sagen
man gewöhnt sich auch dran also nicht
das ist nicht weh tut wenn es richtig
aufpasst vom 10 Meter aber man gewöhnt
sich wirklich dran ich kann mir hier das
erste Mal dass ich vom Film gesprungen
bin
Todesangst habe die die Arme so
ausgestreckt gehabt und habe eben unten
bei den Armen schöne rote Punkte
bekommen dann habe ich gedacht boah das
geht nicht das Leute davon ziehen und
springen aber umso öfter umso leichter
wird und umso mehr gewöhnt man sich ans
anders Gefühl und auch an Schmerzen
manchmal wärst du nicht gescheit dass
man absichtlich falsch springt sich aber
entscheidend also nicht richtig weh tut
aber das hat ein bisschen
klatscht und dann manchmal konnte
manchmal kommst sofort also bei vielen
Vorübungen zum Beispiel wenn ich z.B
einer eineinhalb Auerbach mit dran habe
Schrauben vorbereiten wie vom ein Meter
wenn ich die Vorbereitung richtig macht
muss ich eigentlich richtig
flach am Bauch ankommen und dann ist der
Sprung für ein drei Meter bereit weil
wenn ich fußwärts ganz normal gerade
eintaucht wäre es ein bisschen zu
langsam
also die Vorübungen sind manchmal echt
schlimm aber wie gesagt man gewöhnt sich
dran und das ist es lustig an high
diving dass die halt ihre Vorübungen
schon von zehn Meter machen das heißt da
schon das was du das Ängste auslöst bei
anderen sind die feuerübungen von von
den anderen genau das sagt in Österreich
was für dich leichter die Aufmerksamkeit
zu bekommen und auch deinen Sport dann
umzusetzen wie würdest du denn sagen ist
oder Zustand des wasserspringens in
Österreich hängt ja auch sehr stark von
der Infrastruktur ab genau und die
meisten Türme habe ich in Erinnerung
sind meistens bei dem Freibädern die
haben halt genau zwei Monate offen ja
in Wien Schatz ziemlich gut aus muss ich
sagen also da
ich meine die Türme sind nicht immer
offen sind nicht immer aufgesperrt aber
wir haben meistens guter Möglichkeiten
im stadtteilenbad läuft sehr gut beim
Training in Graz ist ein bisschen
schwieriger da haben wir im Winter nur
in fünf Meter der auch eigentlich nur
zweimal Wache offen ist
aber es läuft gut es ist generell für
ein Wasserspringer egal wo
sehr anstrengend konstant und oft zu
trainieren ohne viel viel Geld
reinzustecken gibt es andere Nationen
die dann eigene Hallen haben nur für
Wasserspringen oder ist das immer so in
Kombination mit einem Schwimmbad ja in
Deutschland zum Beispiel sonst sehr gut
dabei da gibt es teilweise Räume wo
wirklich nur ein 10 Meter Turm und ein
Becken dafür gebaut ist in China
selbstverständlich das ist aber glaube
ich ein anderer Sache es geht schon
besser aber ich glaube es ist auf dem
Weg nach oben in Österreich und du sagst
natürlich auch dass es auf dem Weg nach
oben geht aber du hast jetzt die Musik
schon angesprochen und ich weiß als du
gerade
das teilnehmerweise das dass du dann
dort auch deine DJ Rolle wahrgenommen
wird du hast ja nämlich noch eine
weitere Person nämlich das die Musik was
bedeutet die Musik ja musik ist für mich
immer so eine Sache gewesen nicht ich
liebe ich liebe Musik ich liebe Musik zu
machen zu hören und deswegen habe ich
Anfang Corona mit DJ begonnen mir
gedacht okay lieber als den ganzen Tag
auf der Couch zu liegen und
fernzuschauen mache ich irgendwas oder
lerne ich irgendwas und das ist bis
jetzt gut gelaufen es macht Spaß und
sagt glaube ich einen guten Ausgleich
zum Sparen weil das dich wahrscheinlich
als als junger Mensch auch für die Musik
entscheiden können warum hast du dich
denn für eine Sport entschieden ich
glaube ehrlich gesagt weil mein Vater
dann wieder begonnen hat also das hat
mich so beeindruckt dass ich dass ich
mich dafür entschieden habe ja ja was
hast du dir sportlich vorgenommen was
sind deine Ziele ich will unbedingt zu
den Olympischen Spielen das wäre Ziel
Nummer eins ich bin auch mit dem Team
nach Österreich gezogen und dann einfach
schauen was weitergeht aber Ziel eins
dorthin und dann können wir weiter reden
das heißt dass Paris auf jeden Fall am
Radar geht sich schon aus ist das von
von Qualifikationsmodus vom Viktor hin
ist das möglich das fühlt sich ausgehen
also es wird nicht leicht aber es geht
sich aus ja es gibt noch Zeit ich weiß
auch noch was zum Ausbessern ist mit
Anton läuft wirklich sehr gut sind jetzt
sechs Toren Europa
WM-Finale haben wir geschafft beim
ersten Versuch also nicht unmöglich dann
auf jeden Fall im Rahmen des Machbaren
was solltest du als Kind denn noch alles
so schaffen und erreichen ich glaube ich
habe ich bin ziemlich früh in diesem
Sport
ja
reingegangen sozusagen und und habe
nicht wirklich Zeit gehabt um
nachzudenken zu viel was ich gut ist für
mich also es hat einfach alles
funktioniert hat alles gepasst ich habe
immer mitgemacht immer weiter gemacht
und jetzt bin ich da wenn du mal den
Sport nicht hast was fehlt oder das
Gefühl an
nach dem Sport finde ich wirklich cool
also wenn du
eintauchst und dann raus tauchst aus dem
Wasser und du denkst okay das war jetzt
wirklich ein guten Sprung oder auch wenn
es weh tut boah das war jetzt alles
drinne liegen an sich hat was für mich
was würdest du sagen ist deine deine
größte Qualität deine beste Eigenschaft
ich bin immer bereit weiterzugehen als
die meisten anderen was vielleicht auch
manchmal Nachteil ist weil wenn es
wirklich nicht geht
übertreibe ich vielleicht aber ja ich
bin immer bereit mehr
Motivation zu zeigen
was würdest du sagen ist denn unnützes
Talent etwas was du kannst was Dir
nichts bringt
ich bin ziemlich gut im ausknacksen ich
kann fast alle aller Knochen ausknacksen
das müssen wir dann beibringen weil das
so knackst mir seine Passion von mir
von Olympia ja den Traum den wirst du
dir auf jeden Fall erfüllen wir freuen
uns wenn wir dich auf diesem Weg
begleiten dürfen jetzt auch als Teil des
österreichischen Bundesheers alles Gute
auf jeden Fall dadurch danke danke
fürs dabei sein bis zum nächsten Mal ich
freue mich schon bis dann
[Musik]
[Applaus]